bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
de ce qui constitue la bizarrerie
fondatrice de la mécanique quantique
ce phénomène étrange qui la rend si
contre intuitive ce qu'on appelle le
principe de superposition quantique une
façon de résumer ce principe c'est de
dire qu'un objet quantique comme une
particule peut parfois se trouver dans
une superposition de plusieurs états par
exemple un électron peut se trouver à
deux endroits à la fois où trois ou
quatre ou même une infinité d'endroit
dit comme ça ça fait un peu bizarre
comme si les particules quantiques avait
une sorte de don d'ubiquité
alors en vérité cette formulation être à
plusieurs endroits à la fois c est une
traduction en langage de tous les jours
d'un modèle théorique malheureusement
assez complexe qui est celui de la
mécanique quantique
mais aujourd'hui ensemble on va essayer
de toucher du doigt ce qu'est vraiment
la superposition quantique est ce qui
nous fait dire parfois de façon un peu
cavalière qu'un objet quantique peut
être à plusieurs endroits à la fois
[Musique]
avant de parler de physique quantique je
voudrais commencer par revenir sur la
physique normal non quantique celle
qu'on apprend au lycée et qu'on appelle
la mécanique classique en mécanique
classique quand on étudie le mouvement
des objets on leur attribue en général
une position bien définis dans l'espace
évidemment cette façon de faire n'est
jamais rigoureusement exact puisque les
objets ont toujours une certaine taille
et donc ne se trouve pas en un seul
point l'espace mais soit on les traite
comme des objets ponctuelles ce qu'on
ferait avec une particule par exemple
soit ce qui revient au même
on va s'intéresser seulement à la
position de leur centre de gravité ce
qu'on fait avec une planète où un boulet
de canon quand on calcule leur mouvement
prenons un exemple concret imaginons que
j'ai une balle de tennis que sa position
soit ici à deux mètres du sol
appelons cette position x et que la
balle ne soit soumise qu'à la gravité au
chant de pesanteur est ce que vous
pouvez me prédire quelle va être sa
trajectoire au cours du temps je vous
laisse réfléchir
alors si vous pensez que oui vous pouvez
prédire sa trajectoire et la tracé et
bien vous vous trompez pas ce que là
comme ça on ne peut pas prédire cette
trajectoire et pourquoi
et bien parce que l'évolution de la
balle de tennis va dépendre non
seulement de sa position de départ mais
aussi de sa vitesse initiale
si la vitesse de départ est nul la balle
va tomber verticalement mais suivant la
valeur de cette vitesse elle pourra
avoir d'autres trajectoires
par contre si je vous avais donné dès le
départ sa position x et sa vitesse v
alors là oui vous auriez pu calculer
complètement sa trajectoire en
appliquant les bonne équation une autre
façon de le dire c'est que la donne et
de la position x et de la vitesse v sont
nécessaires pour décrire complètement
l'état de la balle de tennis a bien sûr
on doit aussi spécifié d'autres
caractéristiques comme par exemple sa
masse mais parmi les choses qui sont
susceptibles d'évoluer avec le temps
connaître la position et la vitesse
c'est tout ce dont on a besoin pour
décrire son état à un instant t et
calculer son évolution
maintenant quand on fait une expérience
de ce genre sur un objet on peut
s'intéresser certes à sa position et à
sa vitesse mais aussi éventuellement à
d'autres quantités par exemple sont
l'énergie cinétique son aîné
j potentiel ou bien son moment cinétique
mais toutes ces quantités là s'expriment
en fonction de la position et la vitesse
par exemple l'énergie cinétique c'est un
demi 2ème fois avec arrêt le moment
cinétique cx vectorielle v etc
je vous écris des formules mais elles
sont pas vraiment très importante ici
l'idée essentielle c'est que toutes ces
quantités se calcule à partir de la
position x et la vitesse v ces quantités
on les appelle des observable elles
dépendent de l'état de l'objet elle
évolué au cours du temps et ce sont des
choses qu'on peut vouloir mesurer et
quand on les mesure dans une expérience
on ne trouve pas forcément la valeur
exacte mais avec un appareil de mesure
suffisamment bon on peut les connaître
avec une certaine précision
alors résumons en mécanique classique
quand on a un objet ponctuelles on peut
décrire son état à un instant t en
donnant sa position et sa vitesse
et cet état nous permet de faire deux
choses d'une part calculer l'évolution
de l'objet au cours du temps et notre
part calculée des observable des
fonctions de l'état qui représentent des
trucs mesurables alors à ce stade vous
demandez pourquoi je mets autant de
formalisme pour raconter des choses
assez connu et bien parce que maintenant
ça va me permettre de montrer en quoi la
mécanique quantique est différente mais
avant de plonger dans le monde quantique
je voudrais partir de quelque chose
d'encore plus simple qu'une balle de
tennis
[Musique]
je vous ai présenté ici le cas de
mécanique classique le plus fréquent le
plus naturel celui d'un objet dont
l'état est décrit par une position et
une vitesse c'est simple mais quand on y
réfléchit
vu qu'il y à une infinité de vitesse et
de positions possibles dans l'espace ça
fait déjà une infinité d'état possible
alors on va donc temporairement regarder
un cas encore plus simple ce qu'on
appelle un système à deux états un
système à deux états c'est quelque chose
qui comme son nom l'indiqué n'a que deux
états possibles pas une infinité 1,2
alors par exemple un interrupteur et
ouvert ou fermé un beat en électronique
vous au 01 etc et il se trouve qu'il
existe un système à deux états qu on
utilise souvent dans des expériences de
physique c'est la polarisation des
photons un photon c'est une particules
de lumière comme toutes les particules
quand on fait la physique classique on a
envie de décrire son état en lui
attribuant une position et une vitesse
mais on va oublier ces deux
caractéristiques et on va se concentrer
sur une troisième caractéristique
importante pour un photon ce qu'on
appelle donc sa polarisation la
polarisation de la lumière c'est ce qui
fait qu'avec des filtres dit polariseur
on peut atténuer certaines lumière
venant du ciel ou bien de reflets dans
l'eau on utilise ça pour faire des
lunettes de soleil ou bien en
photographie en physique classique un
photon ne peut avoir que deux
polarisation on les appelle par
convention la polarisation droite et la
polarisation de gauche mais ça n'a pas
vraiment de rapport direct avec nos
notions de droite et gauche un essai la
polarisation d'un photon qui détermine
si le foot on va passer ou pas au
travers d'un filtre polarisant données
si vous avez un filtre gauche
il laissera passer les photons de
polarisation gauche mais pas ceux de
polarisation droite
et puis réciproquement ce principe c'est
ce qui fait qu'on peut utiliser un
filtre pour réduire certains reflets
mais également il permet d'utiliser un
filtre comme un appareil de mesure de la
polarisation
le principe est simple s'il arrive un
photon dont vous ne connaissez pas la
polarisation vous mettez un filtre donné
par exemple gauche et suivant si le
photon traversent ou au contraire est
absorbée vous pouvez connaître quel
était l'état de sa polarisation
en résumé un photon si on oublie les
notions de position haute vitesse en
mécanique classique on va le décrire
comme un système à deux états il est
soit polarisation droite soit pour
l'arrestation gauche ttout et en plus ça
se mesure
c'est super simple et bien maintenant
passons en mécanique quantique
imaginons que vous ayez un appareil à
fabriquer des photons avec dessus des
réglages compliqués que vous ne
comprenez pas forcément très bien la
seule chose que vous garantit le
constructeur de la machine c'est que
pour un réglage donné les photons qui
vont sortir de la machine seront tous
absolument est rigoureusement identique
alors très bien vous choisissez un
réglage vous prenez un filtre par
exemple un filtre gauche et vous le
mettez sur la trajectoire pour mesurer
la polarisation des photons qui sortent
de la machine et là par exemple vous
constatez que les photons traverse tous
le filtre ils ont donc a priori une
polarisation gauche très bien vous
changer les réglages et vous recommencez
l'expérience est là avec ce nouveau
réglage et bien disons les photons sont
tous absorbé par le filtre ce qui
indique qu'ils ont une polarisation
droite
super et puis imaginons que vous testiez
un nouveau réglage et que cette fois
vous observiez que la moitié des photons
sont absorbés tandis que l'autre moitié
traverse le filtre comme si la moitié
des fautes on avait une polarisation
droite et l'autre moitié une
polarisation gauche alors c'est bizarre
parce que le constructeur de la machine
à fabriquer des fautes on vous a bien
garanti que pour un réglage donné ils
étaient tous absolument identique
comment c'est possible qu'ils aient pas
la même polarisation et bien la réponse
c'est qu'ils sont effectivement tous
identiques tous dans le même état
mais qu'ils n'ont pas de polarisation
bien défini ils sont dans un état auquel
on ne peut pas associer une valeur de
polarisation et c'est ça l'idée au coeur
de la mécanique quantique les objet
quantique peuvent être dans un état pour
lequel certaines observable ici la
polarisation n'ont pas de valeur bien
déterminée et noter que ça contraste
complètement avec ce qu'on a en physique
classique en physique classique un objet
a une position une vitesse une énergie
etc
on ne connaît pas forcément on les
mesure pas forcément bien mais il existe
intrinsèquement ce sont des propriétés
bien défini des objets classiques et
bien en mécanique quantique ça ne marche
plus forcément les photons qui sortent
de ma machine ne sont pas ici dans un
état auquel on peut associer une
polarisation bien définis en quelque
sorte on ne peut pas dire qu'ils aient
une polarisation
ce qui est bizarre c'est que même s'ils
n'ont pas de polarisation bien déterminé
quand je mesure cette polarisation avec
mon appareil à filtre j'obtiens pas
comme réponse indéfini ou indéterminée
j'obtiens toujours un résultat
à gauche mais pas toujours le même
suivant les photons mais photons sont
tous absolument dans le même état et
pourtant quand je mesure leur
polarisation j'obtiens différentes
réponses ce qui se passe c'est que pour
chaque photon pris individuellement
la réponse que j'obtiens est le fruit du
hasard et suivant le réglage de ma
machine c'est à dire suivant l'état qui
est commun à tous mes fautes ont les
proportions des deux réponses peuvent
varier avec un certains réglages donc
incertaine état pour les photons qui
sortent je peux avoir 50% de gauche et
50% de droite mais avec un autre réglage
peut avoir 81 % et 20 % ou encore 5% à
95 %
en fait toutes les proportions sont
possibles y compris le cas un peu
spécial que j'avais au début où j'ai 100
% de gauche ou 100% droite
ces deux cas particuliers sont les seuls
auxquels je puisse effectivement
attribue une valeur de polarisation bien
défini mais dans tous les autres cas et
bien il n'y a pas de valeur intrinsèque
mans bien défini on parle d' état
superposé de polarisation est le
résultat d'une mesure va dépendre de
façon fondamentale du hasard alors à ce
stade il peut être tentant de penser
qu'on fait une erreur d'interprétation
je vous affirme que les photons qui
sortent de la machine sont tous
absolument dans le même état mais
peut-être que je me trompe qui a un truc
qui m'échappe
peut-être qu'en raison d'un phénomène
physique encore inconnues les photons
sont en fait différents
ils ont chacun une polarisation bien
défini qui sera juste révélé au moment
de la mesure et que le hasard n'aurait
rien à faire dans le processus de mesure
et bien non ça n'est pas le cas ce n'est
pas un effet d'ignorance je sais c'est
un peu dur à avaler et d'ailleurs il ya
beaucoup de gens qui comprennent mal la
mécanique quantique pour cette raison
mais ici les photons sont vraiment tous
dans le même état est dans un état où la
polarisation n'est pas défini pour ceux
qui voudraient creuser ce point ce qui
nous assure de ça ce sont notamment les
phénomènes d'interférences quantique et
d'intrication et pour vous convaincre je
vous renvoie à mes vidéos sur le fuji
bref en mécanique quantique les objet
quantique sont toujours dans un certain
état mais à un état donné on ne peut
plus forcément attribué des valeurs bien
défini des différentes observables et si
on essaye de faire une mesure d'une
observable on obtiendra bien une réponse
mais il ya une forme de hasard
fondamentale qui va en quelque sorte
déterminer le résultat
parmi les résultats possibles alors
cette constatation elle pose un petit
problème en mécanique classique on a dit
par exemple qu'un objet possède une
position et une vitesse bien défini et
on se sert de ces deux valeurs
pour caractériser l'état un état c'est
la position et la vitesse
si en mécanique quantique les observable
par exemple la polarisation n'ont plus
de valeur bien déterminer comment est ce
qu'on va faire pour caractériser un état
reprenons notre machine à photons
imaginons que pour un certain réglages
on est à la mesure 30% gauche et 70%
droite pour définir l'état des fautes on
est bien on va faire comme un cocktail
on va faire un mélange une superposition
les photons qui sortent ici sont dans
l'état 30% de gauche et 70% de droite et
encore une fois ça veut pas dire que 30%
des photons sont initialement dans la
polarisation gauche les 70% dans la
polarisation droite ils sont vraiment
tous identiques dans cet état 30 70 et
ils ne deviennent différents que quand
on effectue une mesure et que le hasard
choisi gauche pour 30% d'entre eux et
droite pour les 70% restants avec cette
façon de caractériser les états vous
voyez que passer dans le monde quantique
complique considérablement les choses en
physique classique l'état d'un photon
c'est simple c'est droite ou gauche
points deux possibilités en physique
quantique ça peut être 50 50 ou 70 35 95
cents à 0
bref il ya une infinité d'état possible
une manière de le visualiser c'est de
représenter l'état quantique sur un
graphique à deux dimensions
on met en abscisse la quantité de
polarisation gauche dans la
superposition et en ordonnée la quantité
de polarisation droite et on aurait par
exemple ici l'état 50 50
ici l'état à 80 est ici deux états
particuliers à 100,01 étape purement
gauche et 0 sans un état purement droite
d'un point de vue mathématique on
représente les états quantiques comme
des vecteurs
ici on a le vecteur pur gauche ici le
vecteur plus à droite ait par exemple 7
et tabassé 80% du vecteur pur gauche et
20% du vecteur pur droite et n'importe
quel état peut être exprimé de cette
façon là comme un mélange avec des
proportions des étapes furent gauche et
pur droite et là on va pouvoir revenir
un peu sur la terminologie quand un
photon est dans un état 80/20 par
exemple il n'a pas vraiment deux
polarisation à la fois on l'a dit il n'a
pas de polarisation bien définis bien
déterminer ce qui est philosophiquement
un peu différent de dire de polarisation
à la fois et même la formulation il est
dans deux états à la fois elle est
stricto sensu incorrect en fait il est
toujours dans un seul
par définition même de l'idée d'état
d'ailleurs mais cet état est un mélange
une superposition avec des proportions
des deux états un peu particulier que
sont le pur droite et le pur gauche
c'est état particulier les seuls pour
lesquels la polarisation à une valeur
bien défini pour les appels
mathématiquement des états propres et
donc la bonne formulation ça n'est pas
de dire qu'un photon à 2 polarisation à
la fois mais qu'il est dans une
superposition de deux états propre de la
polarisation
[Musique]
bien alors je vous ai raconté tout ça
dans le cadre de la polarisation des
photons parce qu'au niveau classique il
n'y avait que deux états dont six à
simplifier les choses
mais revenons au cas plus standard qui
nous intéresse celui des objets qui se
baladent dans l'espace et ont une
position est bien en mécanique quantique
il se passe avec la position ce qu'on
vient de voir avec la polarisation les
objets peuvent très bien ne plus avoir
de position bien défini alors comme pour
la polarisation il ya des situations
particulières où ils peuvent être dans
un état propre de la position et là
c'est le seul cas où on peut
effectivement leur attribuer une
position mais de façon générale un objet
va être dans un état qui est une
superposition de plusieurs états propre
de la position par exemple on peut
imaginer particules qui soit dans l'état
superposés 30% de l'uci et 70% de la
alors ça veut pas dire qu'elle est aux
deux endroits à la fois en tout cas pas
dans le sens classique de ces termes
ça veut dire que se demander quelle est
sa position n'a pas vraiment de sens
mais que si on essaye de mesurer cette
position et bien la réponse qu'on aura
ce sera ici avec 30% de probabilité est
là avec 70% de probabilités et là je
vais faire mon loup en en remettant une
couche 1 encore une fois ça n'est pas
que la particule serait en fait dans
l'une ou l'autre des positions et qu'on
l'ignoreraient tant qu'on n'a pas mesuré
un nom c'est vraiment qu'elle est dans
un état superposé
c'est vraiment une idée difficile à
avaler c'est pour ça que j'aime bien
aussi cette formulation du langage
courant
qui dit être à deux endroits à la fois
car ça insiste bien sur le fait que ce
n'est pas un effet d'ignorance avec des
probabilités 1
c'est fondamentalement une superposition
et évidemment comme en physique
classique il y à une infinité de
position possible pour un objet est bien
quand on passe en physique quantique
il y à une infinité d'état propre de la
position qu'on peut superposer
comme pour la polarisation tout à
l'heure on peut représenter ça comme un
vecteur
mais comme il ya une infinité d'état
propre et bien je vous laisse vous
convaincre qu'il faudrait une infinité
de dimension pour ce vecteur alors c'est
un petit peu difficile à visualiser mais
mathématiquement ça c'est très bien une
autre façon de l'envisager
c'est de regarder en chaque position
possible de l'espace la valeur qui
indique la quantité de lait va propres
associés et de représenter sa part une
fonction cette fonction reflète alors la
probabilité qu'on a de trouver la
particule à tel ou tel endroit
si j'avais en fait une mesure et c'est
ça qu'on appelle la fonction d'onde en
mécanique quantique
la fonction d'onde permet de représenter
l'état d'un objet quantique et de façon
générale un objet quantique n'a donc pas
de position bien défini on peut la
mesurer cette position et à obtenir une
réponse
mais avant la mesure notre objet
quantique n'a pas vraiment de position
et c'est notamment ce qui se passe dans
un atome quand on a un électron qui
orbitent autour du noyau la fonction
d'onde nous dit alors que cet électron
n'a pas de position bien défini et qu'il
est dans une super position de tout un
tas d ta propre qui correspondent à
différentes positions situées autour du
noyau mais ça n'est pas qu'on ne sait
pas où est l'électron c'est qu'il n'est
nulle part en particulier voilà j'espère
que tout ça vous aura donné une
meilleure vue du principe de
superposition quantique et de comment il
se relie à l'idée intuitif d'être à
plusieurs endroits à la fois
et voyez que tout repose sur l'idée pas
simple mathématiquement de représenter
l'état d'un objet quantique par quelque
chose de beaucoup plus compliqué que
l'état d'un objet classique et pour
lequel les observable non plus forcément
de valeur vient définit ce qui est quand
même fortement perturbé on peut faire un
petit résumé de tout ça en refaisant la
comparaison avec la physique classique
en physique classique l'état un système
ce sont quelques variables bien définis
position vitesse éventuellement
polarisation et c'est alors qu'en
physique quantique c'est juste un
vecteur bizarre dans un espace de
dimension généralement infini en
physique classique les observable sont
une fonction des variables d'état et
elles ont une valeur bien définis qu'on
peut mesurer en physique quantique
elle non plus lent général de valeurs
bien défini et lors d'une mesure les
résultats dépendent de la manière dont
on peut décomposer le vecteur d'état en
état propres de l'observateur et puis un
dernier point pour compléter le tableau
je vous ai dit au début quand physique
classique on pouvait prédire l'évolution
d'un état au cours du temps en utilisant
les bonne équation à celle de newton par
exemple et bien en physique quantique
on a la même chose on peut calculer
l'évolution d'un état au cours du temps
et l'équation qu'on utilise c'est la
fameuse équation de schrödinger mais ce
sera pour une prochaine fois
merci alors sur cette vidéo j'en ferai
d'autres 1 pour approfondir ces thèmes
de physique quantique
en attendant je vous renvoie à mes
autres vidéos sur le sujet et notamment
celle sur l'expérience des fang young la
plus belle expérience de toute la
physique
qui permet de mieux comprendre ses idées
bizarres de superpositions et
d'interférences comme toujours quelques
précisions dans le billet de blog qui
accompagne la vidéo facebook et twitter
c'est pour les accès de la chaîne
abonnez-vous la cloche tout ça et je
vous dis à bientôt pour de nouvelles
vidéos
[Musique]